attack on titans come to be one of the
seminal shows of this generation it's a
show that nearly every anime fan knows
about unless of course you've been
completely out of touch or living behind
a sealed-off wall as the second part of
season 3 is about to release today we'll
be going through the best moments of the
series up until now yes finally the
anime will be continuing after the tense
anticipation a word of warning though
for those who haven't caught up with the
show this video does contain spoilers so
do remember that without further ado
let's get right into it
we start off the list with the moment
where Aaron gets eaten this was one of
the most shocking scenes in the show
after all it's not like you expect the
main character to die within the first
five episodes Aaron and Armin squad are
fighting the Titans but end up getting
picked off quite easily risking his life
Aaron saves arm him pulling him out of a
titans mouth however in the process
Aaron loses his own arm and ends up
being swallowed himself
[Music]
[Music]
this was the first moment that was truly
shocking in a show that continues to
captivate and engage with its twists and
turns next on our list is the reveal of
the Beast item we're introduced to this
Titan in the beginning of season su and
let's be honest this can I completely
caught our attention we're introduced to
this Titan when Mike meets his untimely
demise
everything about this Titan raises
questions why does he look so different
from other Titans why can he talk
how can he control the other Titans he's
shown to possess intelligence as he
inspects the vertical maneuvering
equipment and tries to question Mike we
can be sure that this title will be a
major force to reckon with in the future
yucch sector where the sugar solution is
ooh gosh not okay
hootenanny my own annotation at number
eight its Eumaeus transformation the
hard and often sad connections between
the characters are one of the things we
like about attack on Titan and the story
of relationships between you me and
Krista is a good example of that the
complicated story of love and care
between the girls is greatly depicted in
this scene the readiness of yamir to
disregard everything for the sake of
Krista really amazes me she's ready to
uncover her Titan power for Krista
safety and happiness the climax of the
story is reached at the top tower when
surrounded by giants Lumiere uncovers
herself as a Titan and jumps down to
protect Krista such dedication to a
person leaves us astonished America
[Music]
I mean each title
next up on the list is the retrieval of
Aaron now this was a tense moment where
Aaron was kidnapped by the colossal and
armored Titans and to retrieve their
hope for the survival of humanity the
survey corpse pursue them everyone's
terrified of facing off against these
seemingly impossible odds but they have
to just move ahead into the chaos the
scouts face imminent destruction as they
charge ahead but if they hope to create
any hope for humanity's future they
can't let go of this opportunity to get
Aaron back
Erwin realizes this and prompts them to
attack even while seemingly being taken
down right in front of them however with
a missing arm he returns to battle and
takes the opportunity to cut Aaron free
of vert old as well as severing one of
his grappling lines with Aaron retrieved
Owen bellows for the soldiers to retreat
number six on our list is the reveal of
Aaron's coordinate ability so the scouts
have finally recovered Aaron from the
armored and colossal Titans but faced a
group of erratic Titans as they tried to
escape one of these is the smiling Titan
that had eaten Aaron's mother in the
first episode Aaron tries to invoke his
Titan power but it doesn't work he
screams in frustration ultimately
Hannah's falls victim to this Titan
which finally drives Aaron to the edge
where he awakens his coordinate ability
just after he touches the smiling Titan
he controls all the Titans in the area
to attack the smiling Titan and proceeds
to use these Titans to attack the
armored Titan this is a shocking moment
where Aaron is able to use more of his
powers and is able to completely change
the miserable circumstances that the
scouts are in
[Music]
number five on our list is sure to be a
fan favorite it's the moment where
Levi's faces the female Titan this was
one of the most epic moments of the
first season and we've finally shown how
powerful Levi is in the first season
after joining the scouts the division
heads out in an exercise to practice for
further expeditions unfortunately for
the group though the female Titan
targets them she's intelligent and
capable of hand-to-hand combat she
single-handedly takes down a number of
the scouts to get to Eren after which
Levi and Mikasa chase after the female
Titan once she captures Eren this is
when we see Levi go beast mode from the
OST to the animation what follows is an
amazing display of great strength we
finally realized why Levi is known as
the strongest human soldier
even though the fight itself was
unfortunately short viewers were
definitely not disappointed for the
action that was packed into that amount
of time
[Music]
hi
[Music]
type of wisdom you
next on the list at the moment where
Aaron uses his hardening ability this is
a crucial moment in the story regarding
the hopes placed on Aaron and for humans
in general this is when the group have
been cornered and faced death as rod
Reese is turning into a Titan Levi
raises the same statement that he had in
the first season in the chaos of the
female Titan scenario that being the
Aaron has to make a choice in the first
season he decides to trust his squad but
ends up losing the entire team in the
process however this time around he
believes in himself despite the
miserable conditions he and the group
are rim he grabs a bottle labeled Armour
biting down on it while rushing forward
ultimately he awakens to find that he
was able to use the hardening ability
which was able to save everyone
coldest Kyser
number three on our list is the defeat
of rod Reese the main antagonist in
season three rod Reese is overcome by
his circumstances despite his desire to
try to do some good initially while
trying to recover the founding Titans
power from Aaron he ultimately turns
into one of the biggest Titans the show
has ever revealed even bigger than the
colossal Titan the survey corpse and
Garrison fight the monster but despite
numerous blasts the Titans able to
approach the wall however using a plan
by Erwin Aaron shoves a load of
explosives into the Titans mouth the
survey corpse then tried to cut every
bit of flesh that gets released in the
explosion
hoping to cut the nape of the neck
história who receives some of her
father's memories in the process
ultimately did this
[Music]
number two on our list is the moment
Erin realizes he had eaten his father
this was a big reveal for our hero Erin
where he finally realizes what happened
to him the night of the Titan attack in
the third war this was an amazing moment
packed with intense reveals and scope
for development we've finally shown how
Erin got his Titan powers Grisha
forcibly turns Erin into a Titan where
he ends up eating Grisha himself in this
way the founding Titans power gets
passed on to Erin it's a moment that
shocked Erin into a spiral of
self-hatred and confusion he realizes
that his father had stolen this power
it's a moment of ultimate realization
and knocks him of his perceived views of
the world
since dusty
so you don't wear this did you know our
final top-10 moment is the reveal of the
colossal and armored Titans in one of
the most unique in bizarre moments ever
the true identities of the colossal and
armored Titans are finally revealed
these two Titans have caused much
suffering and despair for Humanity
leading the attack and destroying the
walls in both the invasions of the
Titans it's an ironic and extremely
surprising revelation Eren as well as
viewers of the show are told straight up
by Reiner the he and Burt old are the
armored and colossal Titans respectively
it's completely shocking and how Aaron
reacts is completely relatable all along
humanity's enemies have been hiding
among them this scene brought a huge
impact and reaction from fans and
viewers alike to have one of the biggest
mysteries of the show revealed in such a
completely unnerving manner was amazing
and absolutely genius making all the
questions in confusion fade in the
background of the epic fight that will
take place
so which is your favorite moment from
the series are you as excited as we are
for the next part of the season comment
below hope you enjoyed the video and I
look forward to your continued support
please do subscribe to keep in touch
with all the new videos on this channel
and I'll see you next time on Vinny Chiu
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]